un
euro 53,1 euros 53 1 euros 53 54 pour le
gasoil le prix du gazole n'avait jamais
atteint un tel prix alors qu'en début de
mois le gouvernement avait annoncé une
autre record des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
nous limiterons la rose l'électricité à
10% voilà que les tarifs du gazole
viennent de bondir de 28% après 18 mois
de crise sanitaire
la demande de pétrole repart de plus
belle sans que les pays exportateurs ne
produisent plus un record qui vient
battre l'augmentation de 2018 si on sait
avait fait naître le mouvement des gilet
jaune et ex toujours plus importante qui
pourrait bien provoquer le ras-le-bol
des français augmente tout autour et
chargé on paye en dirigeait france et
derrière c'est un ras-le-bol général
alors le prix du gazole bat son record
en france la colère vettel explosé dans
le pays
merci caméra qui vous fait matthieu
delormeau et 19h44 on est en direct par
françois mercier olive olive d'être avec
no mercy au niveau licence et citoyen
engagé chez les jaunes toujours au
niveau du groupe a gelé jaune aussi
gilet jaune vert rouge violet citoyen
engagé on va dire aujourd'hui c'est
blouson vert alors c'est ça aujourd'hui
celle où l'on va bien et merci à jean
baptiste djebbari ministre délégué
chargé des transports je le dis ça va
être jean baptiste tué barry ça va être
un petit peu animé comme d'habitude mais
c'est vrai comme je le dis à chaque fois
merci en tout cas d'avoir le courage de
venir que ce soit hier voilà la mine la
secrétaire d'état qui est venu à la
jeunesse jean baptiste et barry c'est
vrai qu'au liban libre voilà même si je
sais que même au niveau libre apprécié
le fait que des gens viennent sur le
plateau au moins c'est s'expliquer et
s'exprimer on est d'accord c'est vrai
voilà et ça c'est important parce que
voilà et on préfère ça n'engage à preuve
c'est exactement voilà mais c'est
important en tout cas de discuter bien
sûr et de débattre on préfère ça que les
gens qui devaient y potes qui devient
pas du tout alors justement le prix du
gazole bat son record en france la
colère va-t-elle exploser dans le pays
c'est vrai que c'est c'est incroyable en
atteint des records pourquoi monsieur
nice d'abord il faut comprendre d'avoir
moi aussi je suis ravi de venir débattre
avec vous c'est un quatrième et
cinquième fois et c'est toujours
compliqué mais mais je crois utile il
faut comprendre qu'on a une crise
économique importante fois on l'a tous
vécu et qu'on est dans un moment où
l'économie redémarre ça démarre très
fort en chine sert débat très fort aux
états unis sert des mains en europe et
du coup ça tire les prix vers le haut
notamment les prix du gaz et les prix du
pétrole or le pétrole on ne produit pas
en france on le produit peut en europe
et donc lui les augmentations alors on a
un problème de court terme apprennent de
moyen terme problème de court terme et
d'ailleurs les faits le fmi vient de
dire aujourd'hui qu'on le fonds
monétaire international seulement
s'attendaient à une hausse qui devrait
prendre fin au premier trimestre 2011
donc on sait très bien qu'on a quand
même quelques mois un peu dur devant
nous donc premier sujet c'est comment on
y répond à court terme demain on est une
réunion au niveau européen avec les
commissaires j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à
attirer breton on va regarder tous les
dispositifs qui peuvent être mis en
oeuvre par les états on l'a déjà fait
sur l'électricité sur le gaz la semaine
dernière où il ya quinze jours pour
contrôler les prix contrôler les hausses
éventuelles ont bloqué les prix donc ça
ça va être étudiée au niveau européen
est par ailleurs à court terme on a déjà
en france fait plein de plein de choses
dans l'histoire y compris dans
l'histoire récente on à toucher à la
fiscalité parfois on a aidé ceux qui
étaient les plus gros consommateur de
carburant ça s'est su les court terme et
il faut y répondre ensuite on a su à
moyen terme parce qu'en vrai on produit
pas de pétrole on n'a pas vocation à
produire eux-mêmes plutôt en sortir et
ce faisant on subit quand même les
crises géopolitiques ont subi évidemment
le sujet environnemental et c'est aussi
insuline indépendance pour nous c'est
pour ça qu'on a engagé la transition
vers le véhicule électrique donc là il
ya trois sujets pour nous 1 c'est faire
la transition environnementale et 2 c
c'est aussi rien du ska lisez la france
et trois c'est mieux contrôler les prix
je vous donne un chiffre ces deux mois
on arrive à vraiment produire ou à
transformer notre parc automobile en
parc électrique le plein il approchera
plus des 100 euros comme c'est
actuellement le cas avec nos véhicules
actuels mais ce sera plutôt une recharge
électrique de l'ordre de 10 euros on a
un intérêt objectif ça met un peu de
temps c'est une petit con engager
maintenant on a un ce soir aussi pour un
robin grossmann
pour larry bird et matthieu delormeau
euros on peut rouler on est tranquille a
affirmé être au départ 9 heures d'orgues
50 60 francs en tout cas ça et et salue
la moins pour ceux qui roulent beaucoup
les gros rouleurs ceux qui font qu'on
est facture de carburant élevé à la fin
du mois vraiment mais non faut sortir sa
vie olivo livre quand tu entends tu le
lis tu te dire tout ça qui étudie en
restant très correct là c'est pas
cohérent ce qu'on est en train
d'entendre premièrement on nous dit
qu'on a fait des choses pour le gasoil
pour les transporter en fait n'avait pas
dit mot mais moi j'ai voulu dire en fait
vous l'avez fait pour les transporteurs
parce qu'à un moment donné vous avez
vraiment eu peur qui bloque tout le pays
les transporter à travers toutes les
taxes à son qui pouvait avoir donc ça a
été un moyen de les acheter bien je vais
vous avez bien joué notre jeu comme ça
aujourd'hui les transporteurs on y voit
d'ailleurs ils font plus grève plus
d'autres dispositions qui ont été pris
par d'autres gouvernements avant qu'ils
sont compliquées pour les transporteurs
de fer g vous êtes en train d'expliquer
à tout le monde il faut aller vers le
véhicule électrique le véhicule
électrique électricité c'est 50 %
d'augmentation en cinq ans si on
continue dessus vos coûts je n'ose même
pas imaginer combien ça va coûter dans
dans 5 ou 10 ans c'est la vérité
célébrer chiffres qui sont sans
électricité en train de flamber aussi le
gaz est en train de flamber l'eau est en
train de flamber tout est en train de
flamber en fait les français ils sont
complètement pris à la gorge moi j'ai
une question à vous poser qu'est ce que
vous comprenez pas sincèrement qu est-ce
que vous comprenons pas trois ans de
crise sociale dans notre pays le pire
gouvernement qu'on ait jamais eu des
manifestations tous les services non
mais comment non rien je vous laisse je
vous disais jerry yang âgée langage et
non mais parce que oui je suis désolé
parce que c'est déjà en train de vous
crachez toute la détresse que j'ai au
fond du bim monsieur en train de vous
parler avec mon coeur et c'est la
détresse que les français ils ont parce
qu'ils ont peuvent plus est ce que vous
trouvez normal que dans les foyers
français des moments deux personnes qui
travaillent il n'arrive même pas allé
jusqu'à la fin du mois une étude vient
de sortir 60% des français baisse le
chauffage à 17,2 et dans leurs maisons
parce qu'ils peuvent pas chauffée vous
vous rendez compte quand même là vous
voyez enfin on peut il ya tous les
sujets on peut parler du pouvoir d'achat
et moi je pourrais vous au palais des
nations
je réponds du coup la sg parisy
répondait pouvoir d'achat et depuis 2010
est c'est incontestable y compris pour
les classes moyennes et populaires
pouvoir d'achat depuis 2007 on n'a
jamais eu autant de haut du pouvoir
d'achat depuis 2017 et compris pour les
classes moyennes et populaires que ce
gouvernant pas faux que trouvé personne
parce que moi je le connais bien
maintenant des noms et des objectifs
j'ai bien compris que ma tronche n'est
pas votre truc moi j'essaie de vous
répondre par des faces est bien plutôt
aisément les transporteurs routiers les
transporteurs routiers ça fait des
années qu'ils ont des des allègements
fiscaux le vrai problème et
transporteurs routiers c'est pas la
fiscalité le vrai problème c'est que en
europe s'est organisé une concurrence
intra-européenne et qu'on a été dopée
par les pays de l'est c'est ça le vrai
premier transporteur routier qu'après on
a pu bricoler la fiscalité nous on
essaie de poser une réponse structurelle
sur la protection sociale des
transporteurs routiers ce qu'on a fait
on a été encore une fois le gouvernement
qui fait le plus avancer les choses je
rentre pas dans les détails techniques
mais mais c'est ce qu'on a fait
troisième sujet sur l'électricité et le
prix d'énergie celle là c'est une hausse
conjoncturelle du fait de la reprise
économique le prix d'énergie n'a pas
vocation à augmenter de 50 personnes
tous les ans il faut contrôler la hausse
sur l'électricité sur ça et on a un
sujet et même avant la crise sanitaire
on a
on a un atout en france c'est que notre
énergie électrique à 75% lé nucléaire et
vous voulez l'art et la maîtrisons et
vous voulez l'arrêter on vient de lancer
commencé ce matin ce matin le président
d'un public a annoncé ce matin qu ont
relancé une politique nucléaire pour y
compris maîtriser les prix et je vous ai
donné des chiffres l'objectif à terme
est la réalité l'objectif à terme c'est
d'abord une recharge électrique pour les
véhicules et ricane 10 euros donc ça
sans moi je comprends je comprends tout
ce que vous dites j'ai essayé de vous
exploser les faits si siens parce que
c'est aujourd'hui que les gens c'est pas
son plaisir à faire un petit tour un
petit tour de table des chroniques avait
avec la question qu'on vous a posé le
prix du gazole bat son record en france
la colère va-t-elle exploser dans le
pays
kidioui vous dites oui valérie bénaïm je
sais pas si elle va si les gens vont
retourner dans la rue parce qu'ils sont
fatigués ils sont exempts qu'avec la la
crise sanitaire doit nous dire que c'est
peut-être compliqué en tout cas la
colère est là et on lorient l'entente et
pour quelle raison parce que on parlait
de cesser le prix du gazole notamment
c'est c'est pas c'est pas simple ce
n'est pas anecdotique dans la mesure où
certains certains foyers et quasiment
tous les foyers n'ont pas le choix
notamment l'argent qu'ils ont besoin de
prendre la voiture pour aller travailler
non ils n'ont pas le choix dans leur vie
quotidienne moi j'ai regardé un petit
peu les chiffres cette hausse des prix à
la pompe ça pèse directement sur leur
budget pour les pour les foyers les plus
modestes 10% des revenus pour les plus
aisés ce normand % mais 10% des revenus
quand déjà on tire le diable par la
queue sur évidemment que cet extrait tu
es obligé de le faire monsieur le
ministre nous étions obligés à nommer la
hausse fayyad le sujet quand vous quand
vous ne produisez pas de pétrole vous
acheter du pétrole aujourd'hui comme
tout le monde achète du pétrole la
hausse des prix se fait aux et 6 au
dessus au dessus du prix de base
effectivement il ya des taxes raison
pour laquelle sur tous ces sujets on a
une réunion demain au niveau européen et
j'ai dit sur la hausse du prix
l'électricité et pour le coup du gaz
d'accord on a mis en place un système de
contrôle des prix contrôlés justement là
où cela
a été évoqué un moment gel des taxes et
éventuellement travailler sur la
fiscalité est ce que ces deux pistes
aulas ont exploré les pistes sont
explorées mais moi je le dis il faut pas
se tromper de combat enfin ces sujets
ils reviennent tous les ans tous les
deux ans à chaque crise donc le vrai
sujet structurelles le vrai sujet à long
terme pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français sait comment met on arrive à
semer parce que c'est le vrai successeur
au gasoil se passer de la dépendance une
énergie qu'on a produit un
jeu monsieur mise je comprends tout à
fait ce que dit jean wauthier baril il a
raison mais comme lui au niveau livre
s'est massée en gelée face à son hôte en
difficulté eux il sait maintenant qu'on
fait le chèque énergie
traitement si on sort arrivé à la fin on
est à six mois des périodes des
élections qui vont arriver et là vous
faites encore des belles promesses
que vous savez honnêtement pour le
moment non voilà c'est pas mon nom je
l'ait déjà du sang ce plateau je vais
leur dire ouvertement je suis vraiment
pressé j'ai hâte de voir vraiment un
candidat citoyens pour avoir une
politique citoyenne à l'everest qu'un
candidat qui vous qui vous convient dans
le lot sincèrement non ils font tous
partie du même système moi c'est
aujourd'hui c'est carrément système que
je combats ces systèmes qui me convient
plus haut il ya plus de répartition de
richesses il ya plus
mais si nous arrêtons donc là parce que
c'est vrai qu'il va avoir une élection
en avril prochain sera l'occasion mine
de rien de de faire entendre votre voix
et aujourd'hui vous ne savez pas pour
qui voter non mais je pense qu'il ya des
choses qui vont venir bon c'était un
candidat qui va se déclarer je pense
qu'il ya des choses qui sont en train
d'amener des dettes ramener je t'en ai
déjà parlé ici cyril
et j'espère que ce candidat va émerger
surtout va rassembler tout où toutes ces
personnes qui ont fait un travail
citoyen savait déjà qu'il s'agit voilà
alexandre l'emploi alexandre l'emploi
qui est en train de travailler sur un
sujet et je trouve moi j'ai commencé à
regarder ce qu'il est en train d'établir
sa passe a pas l'air mal en tout cas ça
a l'air d'être un sujet à l'écouté du
peuple moi tout ce que je demanderai si
demain on avait un candidat citoyens qui
pouvaient amener quelque chose un
programme qui pourrait plaire aux
français je lui demande de se mettre à
mende arrêt obligatoire je vous demande
de dire aux français à écouter cette
fois confiance et je me mets un mandat
révocatoire comme ça bah si j'ai pas
respecté mes paroles comme tous les
gouvernements qu'on a depuis des années
et des années des belles promesses et
bien au moins on pourra faire un
référendum et puis changer de et puis
changer changer les choses parce que
attend de 50 c on en a marre en fait
pourquoi il ya 40% des français qui ne
votent plus et qu'ils n'ont plus goût à
la politique il n'y croit plus à chaque
fois c'est des paroles des paroles
lancées en l'air et aucun agissement et
là on arrive en fin de quinquennat et on
nous fait encore des belles promesses on
est allé prendre jusqu'au mois de mars
jusqu'avant les élections mais pour les
français pour des idiots
c'est vraiment l'impression que pendant
la crise où on a parfois arrêter les
secteurs vous avez vraiment l'impression
que les tarnais rien fait pour soutenir
mais j'ai surtout
jamais allés interroger vos collègues
qui ont des bois des petits commerces à
les interroger et regardez regardez ce
qu'a fait cet état français qui est l
état le plus généreux je me fais il est
normal non il a rien fait cellectis et
c'est nous qui payons évidence et qui
nous endettons c'est zéro
gerald mais je vous entends au niveau iv
je comprends absolument votre
exaspération vous soyez à bout vous
venez souvent sur ce plateau vous êtes
souvent en colère vous dites qu'on vient
en dictature moi je pense que tout ce
qui est excessif est insignifiant et
malheureusement vous êtes totalement
obsédée et obnubilée par votre haine
anti macro non moi je considère qu'il ya
plein des routes il ya malgré tout quand
même le couac il en coule ses 240
milliards alors maladie au niveau ligue
ceux qui n'adhèrent avec personne non
mais bien sûr c'est ce qu'ils disent oui
mais sauf que après la crise et gilet
jaune y avait quand même eu un chèque de
17 milliards d'euros me semble-t-il pour
la crise et gilliot ça n'est pas assez
bien sûr mais je pense que c'est quand
même un pas du côté des gilets jaunes et
encore une fois moi je ne crois pas du
tout à une direction alors maintenant
vous faites appeler citoyen engagé parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'il faut surtout
plus du tout appelé le mouvement séjour
essayer de toucher tout le monde parce
que on essaye toujours les gouvernements
et fait fermer tous les écoles et je
veux qu'on sorte de ses 15 mai sauf que
des olives quand il ya dû avoir une
sorte de direction ou de personnes saura
sortir du lot justement dans les gilet
jaune vous avez dû l'exfiltrer parce
qu'en fait vous ne supportiez pas que
quelqu'un soit le leader de ce mouvement
donc en fait moi j'y crois pas du tout
en revanche moi je voulais savoir
pourquoi est ce pas la tva bah oui bah
c'est un des sujets je le dis c'est un
des sujets demain qui va être invoquée
au niveau européen pour savoir puisqu'il
ya des taxes et la tva sur des taxes
donc chez j'ai dit on a bloqué on a
contrôlé les prix de l'énergie
s'agissant du gaz électricité il ya
d'autres mais encore une fois ça résout
un sujet de maintenant juste pourrait se
résoudre à le sujet de l'indépendance
française et de la capi stephen baisser
le point notamment de travailler sur
l'ici et maintenant messieurs et sur les
deux titres sur wii matthieu delormeau
annonce promet d une politique pendant
mais je sais que le jour se levait une
femme politique était là pour ne pas
être la violence à l'école et nous
expliquer que ça n'a jamais été aussi
bien sous blancs caire au moment où on
voyait que quelques sites c'était une
horreur dans ce dossier lycée et que
l'alors le professeur l'a reconnu il ya
en plus pardon devant elle il a reconnu
devant et le que c'est beau
voilà pour dire poser est est là olivo
livre c'est vrai qu'il est il est vrai
une détresse il sait ce qu'il dit c'est
ce qu ils trouvent et il voit la
personne ne lui convient aujourd'hui
mais ils se sont un petit peu mais
coatings parisienne celle que je vois
surtout les français qui vont pas mieux
je voudrais répondre à géraldine juste
par rapport à ça est-ce que vous pensez
que la france va mieux est-ce que vous
pensez que les foyers français vont
mieux ils sont en détresse totale mais
j'en ai tout à fait conscience alors
qu'avec ce qu'est ce qu'on attend bien
faire les choses qui ont été faites mais
nos rires
oui mais
monsieur le ministre quant au niveau
livre dit il ya des foyers qui n'en
peuvent plus et c'est vrai qu'on l'avait
vu lors de la crise des gilet jaune il
ya eu énormément de témoignages de
français je le dis à chaque fois légers
les jaunes sont des français qui sont
qui en ont marre qui sont difficulté qui
le 10 du mois non plus un euro pour
pouvoir vivre jusqu'à la fin du mois et
est ce que vous en avez conscience est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous dit on va essayer
de faire quelque chose pour ces gens là
voilà où est ce que pour l'instant je
sais c'est pas un sujet vraiment d'abord
moi j'ai une famille modeste 4e fois en
banlieue parisienne donc si vous voulez
la fin du mois je connais mon père il
était vendeur à la fnac on avait la
connaissent mais je connais on n'oublie
jamais comme d'hab et je n'avais pas de
procès d'intention mais jamais je pense
que beaucoup de politiques
ces recrutements je les ai reçus j'étais
député à l'époque je me suis et j'avais
des jaunes canal historique d'ailleurs
avant que ce soit un peu repris par les
politiques les syndicats les partis
politiques et je vais effectivement
j'avais un puits soignante un cuistot
chu est évidemment que qu'on connaît ces
situations là on a discuté ne plus de
plusieurs choses mais essentiellement du
pouvoir d'achat et de la politique du
gouvernement et de ce coût serait de ce
qu'ont essayé de faire trois heures de
discussions honnêtement à la fin on
progresse on n'est pas d'accord sur tout
la plupart voteront pas pour nous c'est
pas un sujet mais en progrès c'est la
pression que j'ai c'est que vous vous
aimez vous avez une telle détestation
décliné parce que vous qualifiez comme
système et non moi je compte m c'est
juste c'est ça mais je vois une telle
détresse entre les jours je suis tous
les jours je crois que je n'étais pas
inquiet l'usiné militaire de la phrase
dans ce pays vous dites vous dit il n'y
a pas à payer plus inégalitaire que la
france le pays le plus égalité au monde
celui qui transporte le plus la richesse
des plus riches au moins et c'est la fin
d'un an mais non on ne va pas rentrer
dans ce sujet
de plainte c'est déjà on se met pas
d'accord sur l'évasion fiscale allons-y
d'un cem et que vous avez des solutions
ils sont dans la merde et seule chose
c'est que vous vous faites de la fête
espèce de deux pays dans lequel tout
irait mal or quand on coupa et quand on
connaît un peu l'extérieur sincèrement
on nous envie de l'extérieur on nous
envie pour le quoi qu'il en coûte on
nous envie de distribution de moins en
moins je vous le dis donc il ya des
vrais problèmes il ya un vrai problème
de prospérité dans ce pays mais un vrai
problème d'inégalité croissance il faut
résoudre tout ça ça peut être revenir le
chapeau le truc consensus entre nous
après on divergent sur les solutions
visiblement vous diverger sur ce que
vous appelez vous le système d'un côté
ou préférer les mouvements citoyens mais
moi croyez moi d'abord un on sait ce que
c'est la précarité parfois on l'a connu
parfois on a évidemment des proches qui
la vivent on a vu des six tués les
solutions qui semble-t-il diffèrent mais
moi j'ai pas de propos idéologique et
c'est un propos politique trois
responsables et j'essaie de démontrer
que ce qu'ont fait ces céréales est
tombé oui oui maintenant juste un mot
très court ce que sam shemie cela pour
revenir vraiment sur le sujet du prix du
gasoil vous nous dites patience
électrique arrive le renouvellement du
parc voiture électrique ça va prendre au
minimum 20 en jeu ce qui est dingue
c'est pas comme ryanair à la fin du mois
donc pardon mais encore une fois formulé
des réponses concrètes dans les réponses
concrètes bien au delà de la tva les
socialistes l'avaient fait avant vous il
ya une taxe sur le pétrole la france
fait partie il faut le dire des trois
pays qui taxe le plus le pétrole et
l'essence pourquoi juste cette taxe à
questions concrètes vous n'abaissez pas
c'est 80 % du prix de l'essence 80% de
protestants sa valda pourquoi vous ne
l'avez s'est passé ça j'ai dit que le
module jamais su gérer l'eau gelée dit
on va être sur les techniques sont sur
la table dont on sait ça existait entre
nous c'était en 2000 2002 ça n'a rien
résolu après parce que quand vous
enlevez les taxes des taxes à financer
les services publics oui quand vous
enlevez des taxes en général ou
financées par la dette pas
simplement coupable mais au droit ça
permet à courir ça c'est quand il faut
dire tout le raisonnement est 12e sujet
c'est déjà été fait c'est apporter une
réponse conjoncturelle eu d'autres
dispositifs qui existent et on a aidé
les consommateurs de 21 mois ce qui
roule beaucoup les transporteurs
routiers et d'autres donc si vous voulez
répondre conjoncturellement n'importe
quel gouvernement sait le faire mais le
vrai sujet pas lassé gorille
l'électricité et donc on le fait sur le
gazon et je les dis encore sur le gaz et
demain on a une réunion européenne pour
traiter notamment pas uniquement de ce
sujet là la réalité c'est qu'on peut
aussi se retrouver l'année prochaine si
on engage parce qu'on aime ce qu'on dit
sur l'électrique on peut se retrouver
l'année d'après on sera dans une
situation probablement encore pire on
n'aura rien résolu sur le fond alors pas
recréer d'industrie pas d'emplois chez
nous bah ouais donc il faut essayer de
répondre sur les deux on a beaucoup de
gouvernements qui ont calé qui ont fait
des réponses fiscale justement pour
apaiser le pays le nucléaire c'est
symptomatique ça fait 20 ans que les
politiques ne prennent aucune décision
parce que c'est dangereux politiquement
ce gouvernement prend des décisions à
long terme c'est évidemment gagnants y
compris sur la facture olive olive je
sais que tu as une annonce à faire ce
soir c'est ce qu'on dit mais équipe
c'est qu'elle est on annonce et ben en
fait ça va être très clair et très
simple on a un ministre encore une fois
qui nous met des choses sur la table en
ouvrant un petit peu des promesses on en
discute et on va trouver des solutions à
vous apporter les choses et ce qui s'en
suit on a l'habitude d'entendre ça et
les citoyens c'est pas où les volumes
c'est un problème de citoyens s'est tous
les citoyens qui en ont marre qu'ils
sont pris à la gorge et ils veulent
vraiment des réponses là maintenant tout
de suite alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
très simple à partir samedi prochain on
va faire un appel à tous les citoyens de
france quand vous aurez pas mis les
vraies réponses sur la table tant que
vous aurez pas poser des choses dont
vous n'allez pas nous dire quand vous
n'avez pas baissé le gasoil quand vous
allez pas baisser les taxes et ben on va
ressortir dans la rue monsieur sortir
dans la rue jusqu'à temps que vous nous
donner des réponses si vous voulez pas
que les citoyens ils dans la rue
apporter des réponses concrètes tout de
suite aux citoyens à porter leurs arrêté
de faire du blabla arrêtez de faire des
écritures on veut du concret à portée du
concret et dans ce cas là tout se passe
très bien les gens restent ont
tranquillement chez eux tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est gens là c'est qu'ils
veulent arriver à respirer et à vivre et
à protéger leur en fait ça va être ça
veut dire qu ali wallid ça veut dire
quoi le mouvement va repartir mais bien
sûr il ya un mouvement social qui va
être bien plus grand que le mouvement
des gilets jaunes vous le dis très
honnêtement ça va être un mouvement
rouge vert bleu vert violet saab est un
mouvement de citoyens quand peuvent plus
ils vous ont écouté et vous entendu vous
avez eu tout un quinquennat pour faire
les choses vous n'avez rien faire
regarder dans la détresse sociale qui
pliait quand même temps de regarder
tous les citoyens qui se sentent pas
bien chez eux tous les citoyens qui
pensent avoir un problème tous les
citoyens qui pensent avoir été meurtri
par ce gouvernement sortez de chez vous
sortez de chez vous par n'importe quel
moyen lecteurs de pacifistes complet
parce que c'est important mais sortez de
chez vous alors oui un truc pour ça
s'appelle les élections chez alors
cruellement aujourd'hui on vous dit
qu'on est dans les élections
des maires de leur là vous faites de la
politique j'en écoute du peuple désolé
vous faites de la politique on va verser
à la bouche vous appelez on a en fait de
la mode système monsieur mer souvent
bien des cas merci à vous voulez
rajouter un petit bout non je vais
savoir comment avouer qu'en mai n'est
pas une question sous peu baba non
moi je trouve ça profondément désolant
que la seule solution que nous apporter
ces deux bonnes dans mes gènes leur
mémoire dans une team downey mois
dernier les élections médias ripper
reason qui est prêt à nous représenter
gardant
les mini décembre
[Musique]
pensez aux commerçants c'est à isabelle
mais oui on l'est on les a d'abord quand
vous dites pendant cinq ans rien n'a été
fait vous oublie qu'elle quand même deux
ans qui ont quand même paralysé le pays
c'est quand même pas le gouvernement qui
a créé la baronne vu effectivement
ça c'est profondément malhonnête de dire
que gas aucune n est que tout le monde a
été pendant la dictature l'abandonnait
rapport à d'autres il valait mieux avoir
la pandémie en france que dans des tapis
mais c'est normal qu'on a retrouvé un
taux de chômage ont redit d'avant crise
à pouvoir créer de l'emploi industriel